welcome back to CBS this morning George
Floyd's killing is the latest in a
series of incidents highlighting
tensions between the black community and
police CBS News has spent a past year
looking into policing in America and
surveyed more than 150 police
departments all around the country they
told us about some of the changes
they've made since the 2014 shooting
death of black teenager Michael Brown by
a white police officer and the
subsequent protests in Ferguson Missouri
Jeff Piquet's is in Minneapolis with why
law enforcement professionals feel there
was still so much more work to be done
Jeff good morning good morning Gail and
of those 155 police departments across
the country that we surveyed during that
year long investigation Minneapolis PD
was one of them and 75 percent of the
police departments that responded to our
survey said that they changed their
training after high-profile
controversial police involved incidents
but is that training enough George
Floyd's death is the latest in a long
line of police involved incidents
creating nationwide outrage in March
Brianna Taylor was shot and killed by
Louisville Police inside her home during
an alleged botched drug raid Michael
Brown died at the hands of police in
Eric garner died the same year making
the same plea as Floyd analyst goes on
these problems did not start in the
2000s they have been around forever Matt
Johnson is the former president of the
Los Angeles Police Commission you saw it
in the incident that happened in Central
Park with Amy Cooper when she called
police and said I'm being threatened by
a black man she knew exactly what she
was doing these are historical problems
that go back to slavery if we think that
we do the week of de-escalation training
or a week of anti bias training and
we're gonna solve all the problems
we're totally fooling ourselves
during our year-long investigation we
visited departments across the country
to see their training practices
in Mesa Arizona we saw virtual reality
de-escalation training firearm training
in Ferguson we take people we put them
into boxes and implicit bias training in
New York City where officers are taught
how to identify and minimize the impacts
of negative stereotypes at least 69
percent of departments who responded to
our survey told us they have racial bias
training including Minneapolis Police
they said they've been teaching bias
training since 2015 and de-escalation
training since before 2005 I don't know
that it opened my eyes too much to this
Phoenix officer told us during our
investigation that implicit bias
training can do more harm than good
we agreed to hide his face so he could
speak freely will it change how you do
your job no why not I don't think I was
doing it incorrectly to begin with what
do you think has come out of these
changes that you don't think are good
officers second-guessing their actions
sounds like that could be dangerous
deadly black men are still more likely
to die in police custody than their
white counterparts
spike Maas has been an activist in
Minnesota since 1966 because the news
suppresses the message they're tired
they're tired of being abused tired of
being beaten tired of being killed Gil
Kerlikowske spent more than four decades
in law enforcement before joining the
Obama administration he believes
officers have a duty to intervene when
they see bad behavior if your partner is
using inappropriate force inappropriate
language
you've got a responsibility to take care
of your partner and to stop him or her
from from doing that often the
frustration of officers is that I'm not
like that I don't want to be judged by
what officer shavon did and yet the
reality is they know that they all wear
that blue uniform Johnson says training
needs to be backed up by strong policies
to hold officers accountable you need to
look at who you're hiring
demographically does your department
reflect the demographics of the city are
they policing
neighbors or do they live you know 50
miles outside of town what behaviors are
you rewarding who's getting promoted
he says there are no shortcuts when it
comes to earning the trust of the
community you have to put yourself out
there on a regular basis in a community
and then you have to actually show
progress it's not enough to just talk to
talk you have to walk the lot and I
think people are rightfully skeptical
right now they've heard the words before
but then we keep finding ourselves back
in this situation the Minneapolis Police
Department told us when they completed
that survey that all of its officers had
completed de-escalation training and
implicit bias training and that they had
refresher courses at least once a year
and what that means is that the officer
at the center of this case derrick
shavon would have completed those
courses Anthony yeah young yet we're
telling the story all over again Jeff
thank you
I had the worldwide response to George
Floyd's death how protests turned
violent in Paris because of a case there
involving a police and a black man and a
reminder you can always get the mornings
news by subscribing to the CBS this
morning podcast near today's top stories
in less than 20 minutes we'll be right
back
[Music]